افعلها
[موسيقى]
لقد حدث
هذا التاريخ بدأ للتو بالنسبة لي الآن.
يبدو أننا في المستقبل لن نحصل إلا في يونيو
يمكننا أن نسبب العديد من المشاكل وهذا
سوف نستفيد كثيرا مثل العلامات
نحن لا نرتديه في الشوارع الصغيرة
يمكننا الوصول إلى هناك من خلال هذه المجموعة
يمكن الذهاب والقبض على الجريمة والوقت
يمكن أن تصل إلى هناك من قبل
إلى أجاي
افعلها
وهذا الإعصار هو ثاني أكثر الإعصار الذي يتم الشكوى منه
يمكنك استراحتهم في الأماكن العامة.
مثل، سيكون هناك الكثير من الناس متجمعين هناك
لذا في البداية نعطيه هذه الخرية ونقطعها.
سوف نفعل ذلك مرة أخرى مع كل خطوة
دعونا نفعل ذلك معًا، هذا هو الجولف من كلا الجانبين.
نقلت بشكل جيد أيضا وهذا الذي
شكوى الرئيس تأتي حيث سامي
الهندوس على مرافق مع العسل
أظهر المزيد
MP3
[موسيقى]
افعلها
لقد حدث